you know they don't talk about nitrogen
in the other countries by the way
just the netherlands you know with all
these french that yeah they franchise
these uh these you know this
this attack is happening globally so
the the world economic forum makes a
different menu for each country here
it's a nitrogen right but they don't
even talk about nitrogen next door in
germany you know it's only here and and
and again why would you take some of the
most efficient farmers in the world with
not the most efficient farmers in the
world and knock out their farms
and then get somebody else to do this to
create less food with more chemicals see
it doesn't make any sense
it's just nonsense do you think it's
reasonable to put such a large exporter
of meat under the same emission laws as
other countries like countries in europe
well yeah that's what some of the
farmers and some of the meat industry
are arguing
saying we have to follow the same strict
regulations but we produce so much more
and we have so much less space
is it really fair
well we should have argued that 30 years
ago when we were making the rules like
we made this agreement and we haven't
kept our word to our other european
partners for 30 years so now if we go
back to brussels and argue for leniency
then the european commission will say no
like we haven't we haven't forced you to
take action but we're also not going to
make the rules
looser
[Music]
welcome to episode 156 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm michaela peterson
this is an episode of opposing views
where i speak with individuals on
opposite sides of a contentious issue
this episode discussed the dutch farming
crisis and the origins behind it
this is a topic everyone should be
paying attention to
it isn't an isolated incident
i interviewed nick autens a dutch
political writer for the atlantic
sentinel and michael yan a journalist
and america's most experienced combat
correspondent
we discussed two completely different
views about what started the dutch
farmers protests what the dutch farmers
are trying to achieve the global context
of the crisis the local effects of the
netherlands the efficiency of dutch
farming and more thanks for watching and
enjoy this episode this episode of the
podcast is brought to you by goldco a
leader in the precious metals industry
inflation is at its highest since 1980.
we're currently in a recession although
that's not what the us government would
tell you
in july of 2022 bloomberg reported that
the inflation of average consumer goods
has reached 9.1 percent in the u.s from
the previous year at the same time along
with that the stock market is volatile
and the rate that the government is
spending and printing money is out of
control and has been for a while
these three variables play a crucial
role in determining the value of your
retirement savings this is where gold
code does the most for you
goldco has helped thousands of americans
protect over one billion dollars in
retirement savings as inflation
continues to increase in the wake of a
global pandemic
consider the fact that gold and silver
have historically been a hedge against
inflation translating your money into
gold and silver is a safe way to legally
safeguard your retirement savings in a
way that's tax and penalty free dad has
money in gold i have money in gold it's
a good idea
gold co has an a plus better business
bureau rating and they're currently
offering a promotion that gives
qualifying new customers ten thousand
dollars or more in free silver
even if the health of the economy is
questionable you can still protect your
savings with physical gold and silver
call my friends at goldco today to see
how you can get paid to protect your
retirement
visit mplexgold.com
and they'll give you up to ten thousand
dollars in free silver when you open a
qualifying account that's
mplikesgold.com tell them that i sent
you
michael yan welcome to my podcast thank
you for having me on i'm in the hague uh
netherlands that you know netherlands
has basically two capitals amsterdam and
the hague and tomorrow i'll be in the
other capital
you might say the real capital i don't
know what the dutch will say about that
but i'll be back in amsterdam for a big
protest
wow okay so uh before we get started can
you give me a brief background about who
you are and what it is you do
yes uh i'm michael yan i'm from
winterhaven florida originally but i've
lived overseas most of my life
all over the world i have an office in
thailand i've lived and worked in more
than 80 countries and
as you can see i'm here now i was in
mexico a couple of weeks ago tracking
the migration
which is huge
and before that i was in
texas and panama and colombia and
morocco
greece lithuania tracking migration
issues and food and energy as well
because all of these things are i'm a
war correspondent and all of these
things are important to war right
because war is all about conditions not
that i always do just war that would be
untrue but but i do uh
watch where conflict is and the things
that can bring um you know things that
we need to pay attention to like right
now we see
panama melting down which is something
i've been warning about for some time
now and then panama although it's not
much on the news right now i believe but
you know we've got panama canal there
which obviously is wildly important
and also panama is an invasion corridor
to the united states and there's huge
numbers of people coming from about 150
countries through
asia and africa and south america and
they come through colombia and then they
head to that jungle called the aryan gap
it's a gap of jungle there between
colombia and panama spent months down
there in the last year or so
and from there they just head north and
end up all over the united states and
canada so it's massive right now there's
uh roughly ten thousand uh migrants that
this number will change within hours i
mean there's massive numbers coming in
right now due to various reasons and and
they're heading north and uh
in may of this year there was 310 000
just in may uh illegal uh alien entries
that were known into the united states
three hundred and ten 000 in one month
that were known but that number is
skyrocketing so these are the things i
watch
i watch food i've been warning about
potential famine now since january of
2020 i've learned about it every day
for 30 months now and now it's coming to
pass
and so that's why i'm in europe right
now that's why i'm in the netherlands
because the farmers
are revolting here uh they're not
revolting as in disgusting they are
revolting against the world economic
reform and so uh that they are and
that's why i left mexico and came
straight here uh the german uh farmers
have joined
polish farmers and you may have seen the
italians and spanish as well not to
mention americans i mean this is a big
big deal
okay so this this isn't just farmers in
the netherlands
no this is huge uh you know and i'm a
global player i don't you know i don't
watch just texas or california or
thailand or china i spend a lot of time
in all of these places well i don't
think i can go back to china they kicked
me out of hong kong in 2020 with much
prejudice and actually if they were
smart they would have kicked me out
earlier but
but uh
but i spend a lot of time in asia and
just all over the world actually and so
i'm constantly because everything must
be taken in the context right
and there's there's no truth in the
world without context like for instance
right now
many people are starting to watch panama
in the last few days
and they're trying to judge which way
panama is going to go
and having done this for so many years
around the world i can pretty much make
a good estimate of which way it's going
to go
and watching the context i'm watching
the conditions it's not about sparks
amateurs always talk about sparks like
what will be the spark that sets off the
fire
it's not about that it's about
conditions when the conditions are right
there's always farms if you you can have
a firework factory blow up in a
rainforest but it's rainy and it's a
rainforest and it's not going to catch
the forest on fire but you know in a dry
forest somebody throws out a cigarette
and boom you know town
and so it's about conditions right now
in panama
the global conditions clearly are
deteriorating with energy supplies food
supplies uh transportation
many other things and so
panama sits within panama is a small
boat you might say in a big sea
and uh in the sea that it's in is
getting choppier and choppier and uh in
the panama canal is very important to us
obviously it runs right through panama
and so this is a big deal that's why
i've been watching uh panama so closely
that and some other reasons and and you
see so
watching the conditions
my estimate is that panama will go in a
bad direction which is very serious for
us
and so and that's why i'm here in
netherlands netherlands is arguably the
number two food exporter in the world uh
if this were a small food exporter
somewhere
i wouldn't probably have come because
there's other items on the table that
demand attention as well and so i'm
constantly re-prioritizing and and
trying to go to the things that are that
i sense are the most important and so
that's why i've been watching food and
energy and migration patterns
very intensely since
since january of 2020 when the pandemic
started
in fact i was one of the first by the
way calling out the pandemic i was in
january uh i was loud and clear about it
remember back in january february march
of
2020 when you called it a pandemic you
would be knocked off of social media
yeah and uh and so so i was out there
saying
i think it might be a pandemic you know
i'm not sure but that's the way it looks
and anyway we see how history has
unfolded since then it's been quite
interesting uh and so that's where we're
going right now you can see we're going
we're going into global famines
and uh and that's why i'm here in this
huge food exporter and it's only 17
million people in this country i mean
netherlands is a tiny country
that they've reclaimed much of it from
the sea this is an amazing country i
mean
geographically they've created much of
the country and these are extraordinary
people um and they you know this is i
call it like flat pyramids you can't i
mean the amount of technology and work
that they put into building this country
is so extraordinary and you just can't
uh
imagine i mean you know these old
windmills are so sophisticated uh that
have been you know out working for uh
centuries to
to uh uh you know pump the water out of
the uh
the places that they reclaim and uh and
finally to plant and make this this land
so fertile these are the most efficient
farmers in the world arguably and so
we've got the wef go ahead you wanted to
say something yeah well you said most
efficient they're already the most
efficient farmers in the world they're
extremely efficient and arguably the
most efficient of course you might get
farmers fighting about that so we'll
just let that lay but but yeah probably
the most efficient in the world and uh
certainly let's just say extremely
efficient and uh and and and and uh so
they can get a lot done with a little
bit and much of this is land that they
reclaim from the sea anyway right and so
now with the world economic forum is
specifically targeting netherlands the
dutch farmers and trying to take their
land away and they're succeeding with
some of it right now and they're saying
they're using the excuse of you know
nitrogen and ammonia and all these sorts
of things but in fact in fact that's
chaff that's decoy right it has nothing
to do with nitrogen in fact they don't
say anything about nitrogen to the
german farmers right over the border
which is just close by they don't say
anything to the polish about nitrogen
it's just netherlands because they
with the world economic forum they
tailor make
it's like
i travel around the world watching the
things that they do and ccp you know
chinese communist party i watch a lot of
things but uh
in some of these fights you see are
franchised right it's almost like a fast
food franchise with a different menu in
every country they study
you know how will our
our uh how can we achieve our goals in
this country well here we should you
know according to this culture we should
do this we'll have a different menu here
right so in netherlands they go after
nitrogen right which is just ridiculous
but why would you not why would you
knock out the most efficient or arguably
the most efficient farmers in the world
and take them off of their farms so that
you can get who to do it india you know
i mean
farmers i've spent about a year in india
i mean that's they're not exactly as
efficient as the dutch
to put it mildly and so uh and so
but there's much more at play here for
instance the world economic forum
clearly bill gates is buying up farmland
everywhere uh and and he has he's uh
bill and melinda gates foundation has
invested 600 million dollars in the
picnic food distribution centers one of
which burned down here about two weeks
ago i went to see it hours after they
put it out and uh and it's it's these
food distribution centers that you you
order online with an app
and you don't go to the store and then
they just the the electric vehicles
deliver this food to your home so it
sort of knocks out the grocery store so
basically
with their cricket farms and these sorts
of things
people like bill gates are working to
take complete control over food supply
from production to distribution so
that's just bottom up right
so cricket factory to table right and
but they got to take out these farmers
and another part of this taking out the
farmers that are the most efficient uh
whether that's the united states or here
or germany
uh they're working on something called
tri-state city which almost no americans
have ever heard about tri-state city
many dutch haven't heard of it tri-state
city is the the the world economic forum
are working to take this land for
another goal tri-state city is this mega
city that's planned between the
tri-states of belgium germany and
netherlands and that
tri-state border area
it'll be a mega smart city these smart
cities are you know basically
making us the farm animals so they want
to take out these farmers the freezing
farmers and and take their land and make
this tri-state city and then they'll
have control of that food supply right
and another problem with farmers is
they have common sense and they think
for themselves right so this has been a
constant problem for authoritarians
farmers have always been a needle in the
in the side for authoritarians for
instance in ukraine for stalin
he wanted to knock out the farmers which
so they labeled them kulak's the the uh
the ukrainian farmers and uh and so
basically kulak became a very bad word
nobody wanted to be called a kulak and
so they they uh labeled them and and
started attacking and did the uh the
lotta more famine between especially
1932 and 33 and killed billions right
and took their land and replaced the
farmers with other farmers who were not
as good by the way which created more
famine right and so and now did the same
thing so this is a common thing with
farmers farmers they have their own
cultures they have their own ways they
don't do what the boss wants them to do
the boss being whoever the authoritarian
of the day is and so these
authoritarians always want to go for the
farmers another important aspect of the
dutch farmers is they are one of the
backbones of the culture of this country
right
and so you'll see the
mark
is the uh is the prime minister of
netherlands right margaret and you can
see klaus schwab the
the let's say the mafia boss of the
world economic forum
specifically
um praising mark
in front of a crowd of his you know dark
cult let's call it and you know he's
like where can you get such a prime
minister or something like that you can
see the video you know it must have been
making trudeau quite jealous actually
you know because he and trudeau or
mark ruta and trudeau are a couple of
his boys right and marco ruta's like yes
you know you know
you know margarita is just a boy of the
world economic forum as is trudeau and
as are many others right and so
they
if they can take out these farmers
they'll do multiple things at once gain
more control over the global food supply
gain
that means production and distribution
and and uh and also break the backbone
of the culture back the cultural
backbone psychological backbone of the
netherlands so they're of the dutch
people and so they're
the wef has been pushing this massive
migration into europe as you know and
north america and this of course is
support you go out to some of these
small villages and you look around and
it's mostly people from middle east and
africa and this is dutch villages who
what are they going to do take over the
farms stalin did this back in in ukraine
right
replace the farmers the kulak farmers
with russians and the russians were just
unable to farm and not just russians but
it was often people from the cities who
really didn't know it i guess you know
it appears there's a great book on this
called red famine you know it appears
that those authoritarians just thought
anybody can run a farm yeah yeah it's
easy not like anybody yeah it's like
here's a spaceship anybody can fly a
spaceship they don't realize that's a
lot of knowledge it's not just knowledge
it's also
it's a way of life it's hard work it's
seven days a week so when i was down in
mexico a couple of weeks ago and i saw
dutch farmers
um
you know starting to protest or they've
been doing it for two and a half years
and uh at least two and a half years oh
so it hasn't just it hasn't just been a
month-long thing this has been happening
for years it's it's it's picking up now
it's picking up so when i so when i see
farmers in all the countries i go to as
a workhorse one i'd instantly look for
farmers i look for truckers i look for i
talked with law enforcement military
what do you think about the military
what do you think about the police
government but you really want to talk
with farmers when you see farmers
starting to are the truckers in canada
when you see them starting to take to
the streets these are people that don't
want to waste a lot of energy
they're not baristas or something you
know what i mean they're not just going
to get upset these farmers they work
seven days a week you know at the end of
the day they go to bed you know what i
mean they and they wake up early and
they go right back to work so when you
see a bunch of farmers out on the street
you need to stop
and go and say what's the problem why
are there a thousand tractors on the
road uh because i know something's wrong
it's a thousand every every country i go
to i can get along with the farmers i
don't care where it is when i was in
afghanistan for two years i was out with
farmers all the time iraq too i can get
along with them and and uh
thailand nepal india and china it
doesn't matter they all have common
sense you know
and they all don't like to waste energy
so when the farmers are upset
you need to stop and ask them so these
farmers
unlike many farmers in the world like
down in panama
where i've been spending a lot of time
recently uh the farmers there are more
like you know they just they have
simpler needs they just want
cheap gas just fix the cheap the gas
thing just you know fix a little little
things if you tweak this i'll be happy
but these farmers here in netherlands
are more sophisticated they realize that
this is a big game like they are all
highly cognizant of uh
the world economic forum and schwab and
all these relationships you know with
the picnic food distributions and the
cricket factor you know they don't most
of them don't even want to talk about
nitrogen because they know it's nonsense
right they know it's just chaff it's
just a decoy and and it's all about
taking their land knocking them off the
land taking control of the food
production and distribution and complete
control authoritarian control now look
at ukraine if you were to design a war
last year i was in lithuania attracting
migration from belarus over to uh into
ukraine right lukashinko the the
dictator was pushing and he still is
even yesterday pushing migrants to to
lithuania so i flew from africa up to
lithuania last year
to ask what's up with these
migrants belarus pushing migrants trying
to push them into poland and trying to
push them into lithuania uh something's
up i mean to me that's a signal right
that's not noise yeah and and poland
wasn't letting him in and poland's not
like that i lived in poland two years
poland is just not going to to roll over
that's not how poland rolls right and
lithuania is hardcore too actually
they're pretty serious people and uh the
so the lithuanians saw i i said hey
i'm down in morocco what's going on am i
fly up here we'll give you complete
access so i flew up to lithuania got
complete access for three weeks a month
elected officials army police border
patrol access to the camps where they
were holding the migrants and i started
warning about russia doing something
either to the baltic states or perhaps
to ukraine you see now it's ukraine but
if you're what i'm getting to with all
this is none of this just started right
it's all been building and and not only
that this whole region is always i call
it the middle east for white people you
know i lived in europe for six years
right i mean this is a fractious area we
always look at the middle east as a
complex area where everybody always
fights each other well that's europe too
actually it's just that since world war
ii
we've had
the us army and the us military station
over here very thickly and i was i used
to be a soldier actually stationed in
germany so i mean we kept
we kept the place you know
mostly peaceful actually for the most
part and so it was very prosperous that
those days are coming to an end and and
the old fractiousness is acting up again
so bottom line is
if you were to to design a war to create
global or to exacerbate the conditions
that lead to global famine that would be
ukraine russia right another good target
why evil would be of the energy
uh
for instance
nordstrom uh the gas supplies that are
coming from
russia to europe
luckily russia just turned on nordstrom
again in the last i don't know 18 hours
or so that's probably about right uh you
know they
your germany in particular is so
dependent upon russia for energy it's
unbelievable so you got germany over
here going yay let's help you know
ukraine go to war i'm like hey you know
russia has you by the throat you know
what i mean if you don't know what your
throat if you don't know how important
your throat is
putin sure does so putin shut off
nordstrom a few days about what five
days ago for annual maintenance and you
know everybody's starting to worry about
keep in mind
uh the the liquid natural gas that they
need to run many of those factories and
whatnot is also needed for the haber
bosch process which is used to make
ammonium nitrate
fertilizer which is vital and important
right now they can make up a lot of that
natural gas from the united states much
of which ships out of texas however
roughly one month ago maybe three weeks
we had an explosion which you can find
on the news yeah at a texas park so that
explosion at the that uh at that uh port
at the lng facility
curtailed our natural gas
exports to europe and then we had an
explosion of a field on the pipeline in
texas so that's two and then we had an
accident at or whatever happened in
oklahoma at an lng facility bang bang
bang three right in a row in the last
about three weeks wow
you know russia's got uh just uh is
throttling europe and meanwhile you've
got people like zelinski telling canada
don't send that terp there's a turbine
that you have up in canada to refer that
needs to be refurbished to for just
maintenance right and but it me that
turbine is needed to make the nordstrom
pipe north stream one pipeline work
right and uh and zielinski over in
ukraine is saying don't send it back and
he's you know he's he's hitting on
canada like you can't send it back in
germany you shouldn't
he's basically
zielinski uh you know the t-shirt man
over in ukraine uh is telling germany
just freeze to death this winter because
you know we need we need we need to
to uh cut off russia's uh that you know
money uh pipeline it's not gonna cut off
russia's uh uh hard currency they're
they're selling
to
a hard currency is going to have a new
meaning here soon but they're selling
also now oh they're opening more uh
sales routes to saudi arabia through uh
china through
uh india i mean it's not russia
when you're dealing with russians
they're very smart you know they're you
can't just walk in and and beat up the
russians you know
they they're thinking people they play
chess in many dimensions yeah and and
you know these people that predicted
that this ukraine war would be over very
quickly i'm like hold on rambo that's
not how this goes you either haven't
been in a lot of wars or or or you're
trying to sell something because that's
not how this works and those are
russians they're not little chumps
you're not going to just come push them
around they've got all kinds of buttons
and valves that they can you know
manipulate and they're doing it
wow you really have sorry
no no you've just have an eye on this
from on uh a world level it's very
interesting it's very i'm constantly
walking the line so
whether it's you know afghanistan or
iraq or sri lanka you know last time i
was in sri lanka which was what i don't
know five years ago or so uh
maybe
maybe five there was plenty of food
there was you know
the land of plenty right and yet the wef
world economic forum same ones are
hitting us here in
netherlands i say us because the farmers
whenever i see farmers uprising i stop
like what's going on here should i get
on an airplane and go talk with these
farmers and uh so they you know the
world economic forum somehow persuaded
probably through
you know
payoffs i don't know how they did it
specifically it doesn't matter the
mechanisms are not specifically
important but they got the government of
sri lanka to the wf got the government
of sri lanka to go
organic which is now leading to well the
government well sri lanka is now you
know a failed state and it got it went
from a stable country
almost instantly to a failed state think
about that and one of the things that's
interesting about famine
let's talk about pan from war pandemic
famine war and migration pandemic famine
war this is a triangle of death
these three things always go together
pandemic famine war if you get a big one
pandemic you're going to get famine and
war if you get big famine you'll get the
other two if you get a war you'll get
the other two right if you get three
musketeers you get one you get them all
right i'm not talking about a small you
know go invade grenada and have a
shootout for a week i'm talking about a
really serious one you're always going
to have feminine pandemic right
and
and and then that creates this human
osmotic pressure the push and pull of
migration there's many things that
create the human osmotic pressure in the
hop uh it can be just economics there's
the positive pressure which is like a
fire you know like a war a pandemic
famine that positive pressure that
pushes you out like we gotta get out of
here you know a war you know fire let's
run from the fire uh and then there's
the negative pressure that pulls you in
like let's go to canada because that's a
nice place right so you've got the
vacuum or the thing that sucks you in
right and so uh so there's the positive
and the negative pressure right and so
so anytime you get the triangle of death
it gets ramped up here and that's why in
january of 2020 i started warning about
famine because this is all i do is study
war and conflict and migration and
famine and by the when this pandemic
kicked off i had already read 40 books
four zero books on pandemic before it
started and then during lockdown i read
20 more right and so likewise i study
famine just as hard and so you know i'm
watching these things and
now people are starting to ask why are
you so far ahead on the famine i'm like
because i know when you get one get the
other two that's just how it goes
and it's funny i was talking about this
one time on an interview maybe a year
ago and a lady said you talk about this
like you discovered it yourself and i'm
like well i kind of did and she goes no
it's in the bible i was like wait a
minute it is in the bible they so
so they knew about it two thousand years
ago you know what i mean they it's so i
mean and so i started looking back and i
looked up many of these uh scriptures in
the bible i'm like they were clearly
describing pandemic famine poor horsemen
i mean you know it's crystal clear but
me studying war reading hundreds of
books on war spending years and wars
studying pandemic seeing
food shortages you know i'm just
watching it on the ground and reading
about it in books and realizing wow if
you get one you're definitely getting
the other two it's like if you so famine
also creates famine when you get famine
it creates more famine like fire creates
fire or creates war famine creates
famine why does famine create famine it
famine creates famine uh through various
mechanisms one is once you go into the
initial food shortages and people are
hungry they're gonna they're gonna start
stealing stuff because they're hungry
they're not criminals they're hungry
people right they're going to do what
life tells them to do which is eat so
they start robbing the stores which is
happening in panama right now as we
speak i'm getting almost hourly updates
from panama they're robbing stores
robbing the trucks robbing the trains so
those things will stop flowing right so
that makes it worse right so then people
start to rob the farms and also the
governments always do price controls
when you get into famine every time and
the government just started price
controls in egypt and also um
panama and other places right what is
that so the price controls all
price controls for instance um
controlling the price of gas like you
know we have to stop the gas at 325 a
gallon in panama
they just
made an agreement to make it 3.25 i
think they signed that agreement and
immediately that didn't work and they
started fighting again but the bottom
line is that won't hold because they you
know they set the price of at such a
level that the
the the station you know the business
people can't afford to do it right so
you'll get the gas that went through and
as long as they can keep the subsidies
going but then
you know you can okay the price of gas
is 325 but you can't get the gas right
you can't get the diesel so yeah you got
a low price but if you can get it and
you can right so this
in turn
it's a complex system that starts to
break down right in other words the
tractors don't work in other words you
don't get the fertilizer that you need
so famine creates famine through various
mechanisms one is the price controls are
counterproductive they stop farmers from
growing because the farmers can't make
money right and another thing is
governments start taking from the
farmers direct like they're doing in
egypt right now forcing the farmers to
sell to only
approved uh
warehouses that sort of thing that's
what's mounted that's what stalin did
that's what they always do without
exception again because the government's
like uh oh we're in trouble we need to
do price controls we need to start
taking journal the food supply right so
they start going home to home and house
to house and redistributing food
that's only band-aids and then and then
people start robbing directly from the
farmers that's why when you saw these
huge migrations into europe and about
2016 or so
i kept warning i lived in europe for six
years i started warning uh you know the
uh
you don't understand what's going to
happen i spend so much time in their
countries they will start robbing
directly from the farmers and at first
it'll just be a pain but the moment that
you have something serious going on
the farmers will stop growing so this is
a again so the food
that initial famine that you tend to get
will will exacerbate and and explode
right it will it will increase because
the farmers will stop planting they'll
stop uh doing their farm work right
and so then you end up with
that second season of the famine is
worse now as the months unfold and the
food
supplies dwindle
and the nutritional health of let's say
10 million or 20 million or 100 million
people you know you've got a whole
society now that's malnourished
their immune systems are weakened and
you can see where this is going imagine
tens of millions of people or hundreds
of millions of people with weakened
immune systems
pandemic right and so you'll get
something called famine fevers and all
the big famines you always get famine
fevers one of the famine fevers is
typhus another one is relapsing fevers
and then there's others and then you get
waterborne illnesses like cholera
and these things often in famine more
people actually die from from the
diseases than the actual famines uh
because it's all part of the same system
right they're not they're not really
separable so they feed into each other
and the weaker you get the less able you
are to defend yourself but when i say
defend yourself that might mean just
growing crops right so you know and it
just gets worse and it melts down for
some period of time so that's what we're
looking at now we're on that front
there's different types of famines as
well there's like i call them a light
switch famine the one that's kind of
sudden it can kind of start and and then
can and it can end quickly or slowly but
for instance in here in netherlands
in 1944 45 they had something called the
hunger venture the hunger winter
that was when the nazis came in and
destroyed a lot of the food production
and distribution facilities seized a lot
of the food because the the dutch will
resist seeing them and the nazis wanted
to knock them in the head so they did so
with their food and so that famine was
very sudden it started very quickly and
then americans and others came through
with uh market garden and other
operations and and swept the germans out
of uh
netherlands and the famine was over very
quickly roughly six months or so the
famine was was over right but many other
famines they start very slowly and they
gradually pick up and most famines don't
last for more than a couple of years uh
but there are others that last seven ten
years even longer right
these are the slower gradual famines you
kind of gradually fade into it
and then you reach some you know if
you'll have wars in the in the interim
and lots of disease
and then you'll slowly
leave it right so we're in that circle
of life uh you know it's not like
not like that we're going through
something that's never been done before
i mean this is
this is it our ancestors have all been
through this stuff and we're about to
see it ourselves
so i i spoke to somebody from the
netherlands a journalist reporting there
and his view was that the netherlands
has been producing too much nitrogen
that they've been producing too much
nitrogen
for the last 30 years and that
it was kind of a law passed from the
european union
into the netherlands and that they need
to do this because they're destroying
insect
species and
it's affecting birds in the netherlands
because of all the pollution that has to
do with livestock
what do you think about that story
uh
the journalist is a shill uh you know
it's it's clearly clearly a shell uh and
and it's it's it's bs don't just say it
flatly it's [ __ ] uh you know the um
it's just you know they don't talk about
nitrogen in the other countries by the
way
just netherlands you know with all these
french that yeah they franchise these uh
these you know this
this attack is happening globally so
the the world economic forum makes a
different menu for each country here
it's a nitrogen right but they don't
even talk about nitrogen next door in
germany you know it's only here and and
and again why would you take some of the
most efficient farmers in the world if
not the most efficient farmers in the
world and knock out their farms
and then get somebody else to do this to
create less food with more chemicals see
it doesn't make any sense
it's just nonsense and you know and and
but go ahead
i think their view was well each country
has a limit the amount of nitrogen they
can produce and because the netherlands
produces so much food and they're small
they produce over the limit and so this
is these are laws that were made in the
90s and because they're producing over
the limit they just have to produce less
they're actually not laws it's
bureaucratic nonsense that comes from
brussels right and so basically we've
got bureaucrats like the epa in the
united states the the uh
you know the environmental protection
agency which by the way let me clarify
something as somebody who
travels the world extensively
like china sometimes they're probably
not going to let me back in china again
but when you're landing in beijing or
shanghai or other especially beijing i
mean there's so much pollution down
there it looks like your airplane's
gonna get stuck in it before it lands
like you're gonna get stuck in the amber
it's really bad and it's likewise in
india so when you're in countries like
this and you see how terrible those
rivers are they're like okay i'll take
some epa you know we need some epa you
know you know i understand it i want it
but then these these organizations these
uh like the epa
and the cdc in the united states and
others they become abusive they become
tools for authoritarians to make to
bureaucratically make quote-unquote laws
uh these bureaucrats who how are they
even did they even get into their
positions in brussels right
nobody even knows who they are right so
they come up with these these
these uh edicts these mandates you might
say they're just rules they're not laws
and they say well you know we're the eu
and where we tell everybody in the eu
what to do therefore the dutch farmers
can't produce so much nitrogen you know
these are probably people that never
took a chemistry class in their life 78
of the air that we breathe 78 of that
nitrogen every breath we take right now
is 78 nitrogen right
the whole fertilizer the plants can't
grow without nitrogen the whole world
our lives revolve around nitrogen right
so i mean it's just nonsense but so when
you're chasing that nonsense though and
you start talking about they're winning
they're absolutely winning as somebody
who studies information more
remember the kinetic wars you know the
gun fights and all that stuff which i
did years of that in various wars and
conflicts very tuned into that kinetic
side
that's the high school level of war phd
level war is information work right
it's all between the ears it's and and
i've written three books on information
war i've actually written six books but
three were just on information
unfortunately they're only in japanese
because i've been focused uh for some
time trying to wake up the japanese
about the information wars that their or
their that they are undergoing right and
so when and i see what they're doing in
japan i see what they're doing in china
you know i see what they're doing in
philippines entirely and trying to split
thailand in three parts they're doing
the same in malaysia trying to get
indonesians and malaysians to fight each
other like with musical uh you know
appropriation like you know look at look
at the fights between indonesia and
malaysia about uh who who started the
music you know what i mean they get
people to fight about this little
nonsense stuff you know and the next
thing you know it's like you know people
beating each other up in the streets
about it
or who can wear a kimono you know
japanese don't like people wearing
kimono dresses which is nonsense
japanese are
i deal with japanese constantly
literally seven days a week right i've
written three books that are only in
japanese so i wrote them in english but
they were published only in japan trying
to wake up the japanese to information
what i'm getting to is information more
is my backyard right uh and my front
yard you know so i you know and uh and
so when i look at the nitrogen thing i
just see it for this that's chat like
recently i was off in morocco with a
workhorse friend of mine named chuck
holton
and and there's this new language on the
road signs and i was like chuck what
language is this that's not arabic it's
certainly not english
and uh it's no in fact it's no language
that i've ever seen before
and
and he's like i don't know and
it looked like some strange language i
said you know what i'll bet that's some
information campaign and so get back to
the hotel and look up you know strange
language road science morocco well it's
this new uh written language for berber
class of languages berber is not a
language class of languages right and
they don't it's a they don't have a
written language for berber so
they've come up with this new written
language for berber and now there was
some controversy in the beginning if
you're going to have a new written
language for berber it should be in like
modified arabic you said they all
they already know the arabic alphabet
everybody knows how to pronounce the
letters and that sort of thing but no
they just made up a new line you should
look up this verb
alphabet it looks like furby's talking
to each other it's like computers
talking to each other these strange
symbols but this is how you get people
to fight each other right we get
everybody to start fighting over little
things about you know get the french
speakers to fight the english speakers
some of that will be organic so when
you're trying to get
people to fight each other you find
little frictions that they already have
and you pour the salt on or you just
come in and make stuff up right like hey
that nitrogen is really poisonous it's
killing the insects or whatever you know
and uh and uh you know it's killing
these bugs so let's take the most
efficient or arguably the most efficient
farmers in the world and get somebody
else to do it right and to make the food
it doesn't make sense so but for me
since this is what i do seven days a
week
it's really obvious so i don't i don't i
won't even argue about the nitrogen
thing because i deal with this in so
many countries right
but in every country it'll be something
else it'll always be something else oh
you grow a different type of potato than
we do or something you know they'll
start fighting about hey we invented
that potato and you know
so
how many things you'll see
what's the reason behind getting people
to fight what's the end goal here oh
divide and conquer uh for instance
there's an information campaign now
against the farmers in
netherlands so for instance yesterday
when i did uh interviews um actually
with your father right which is
incredible interviews and uh
while we were waiting i'm talking
naturally i'm interviewing everybody
around me you know what i mean so
there's a lot of camera and audio and
the makeup ladies doing my makeup you
know you know and i had makeup on and so
and so uh and uh
and and i asked her about the farmers
and all that she's oh yes you know they
say bad things about the farmers on the
news you know they're blocking the
streets and stuff so there's some kind
of anger building up from some people
against the farmers and i said oh that's
interesting because that's what they do
everywhere so the farmers rise up and
that's your backbone that's the people
you should be defending right like if
the farmers are rising up i'm just going
to be like i need to drive out and talk
with farmers you know and instead
they're like hey the farmers are bad
guys that's what stalin did and
labeling the farmers
hey but that's why your food prices are
high because the farmers are making so
much money that's why you know this
that's why that the farmers are the
problems you do an information war
against the farmers and then you know
and then then you
cause many problems for the farmers and
then the farmers start to act up or the
truckers in canada and then you start to
demonize the truckers or the farmers
right and by the way the truckers in
canada were very inspirational for
truckers in the united states i drove
all the way across the united states
with truckers from california to
washington dc
because they took the lead from the
truckers in canada they were flying
canadian flags all across america i
talked with your dad about that and
nobody he didn't even know it i was like
it was unbelievable there was hundreds
of thousands of people on the side of
there i drove all the way from
california i was jumping from truck to
truck i went for it with them for like
two weeks right and so i was listening
to the truckers talk hundreds of
thousands of people canadian flags
everywhere they were being americans
flying canadian flags i said we should
have taken the lead they're like well
canadians took it so we're flying their
flags right beside ours right i said wow
go canada and they're saying that here a
lot of farmers here too are or i don't
think canadians even know this the
canadians know that the effect that the
the that your truckers had was actually
important was very important it looks
like the thing just died out in canada
but it didn't it's good you know and so
it's it's it's it's it's you know it's
out here and it's growing still
and um that here's here's the thing in
in the netherlands now they're flying
the flags upside down and converted
right that's what we do in the united
states when you're under duress right
you fly the flag upside down so here you
know their flag is red white and blue
three stripes so they just inverted blue
white and red so yeah about maybe 10
days ago the government said hey these
are representing a danger of flying over
the bridges and
the danger is people take a photo of it
with their phone and put it on instagram
and
and it spreads right and so the
government started taking these things
down and that sort of thing and people
you know other people i started putting
more of them right so i mean the bottom
line is
the demonization of the farmers it's
happened over and over and over around
the world authority
mao did it with in china there's a great
book on this called mao's great famine
it's a great book there's another book
with stalin doing it in ukraine ukraine
a ukraine which is called a red famine
and it goes into detail about the
demonization of the farmers and so when
i hear when i was getting ready to do
the interview with your father and the
makeup ladies doing the makeup i'm like
what do you think about the farmers you
know and she's like oh you know she she
liked the farmers everybody here and
those farmers uh but she's like wow you
know they're saying some bad things
about them on the news
and i said oh it's the normal
demonization process and um
and she went on about it and so i talked
after the interview yesterday we sat
down and had dinner together numerous
others and we talked about things for a
while so it's it's the sort of thing
that i see all over the world every i
spent a year again in the in the war out
in uh
in uh in nepal with the malice right
i've walked up to mount everest in the
in the meantime just to the bottom and
you know i was walking walking all over
that i've walked all over those
mountains man that's some serious mounds
and uh and i was out with the malice all
the time and asking them what's up and
all i would hire guides to carry my
books you know now i got this thing i'd
carry like a thousand books on it right
but back then i had a big pelican case i
had to rent the horse at one point to
carry my pelican case filled with books
so i'd have like candles or eating books
and you know but these mouths they're
like you know they would they could
never persuade me to be a mouse they
would never hurt me because i would just
be like ah that amount of stuff is
nonsense you know but they would if i
were nepalese they would have killed me
for sure but they would just say god you
know whatever come on let's walk you
know
but you know
but the malice were trying to get
everybody to divide get everybody to
split up you can't get people to
cooperate you go over to afghanistan
where i spent two years
all the different ethnic groups they
just naturally are fractious they they
can't
get it together you always have to have
an outside force
to come together that's a force let's
say influence or
or spackle let's say that comes and gets
or gets grouped like the nepalese it's
never going to be a really wealthy
country because they always fight each
other you know it's always like this
group fights that group so if you want
to take the country over you just
exacerbate those fights it's the same in
in afghanistan it was the same in india
until the british came right so you know
i spent almost a year in india as well
the indians they'll have a love hate
with the british they're like well you
know
the british did this that the other was
very bad but the the indians will give
credit where credit's due they're like
but you know they did teach they did
give us a common language uh helped us
with the
railways and these sorts of things and
now india is
you know is really made some really
great they're really coming along but
all these disparate groups fighting each
other this is this is unconventional
warfare 101 divide and conquer and
that's what wef world economic forum or
they call it netherlands west
that's their number one
the substrate of their war is divide and
conquer before you know it they'll have
canada in the united states wanting to
go to war with each other or something
you know they'll figure out how to do
that somehow right
this episode is sponsored by better fed
beef a direct to consumer company based
in the american midwest that produces a
highly consistent beef product called
certified anya beef
these beauties
look at this marbling
this stuff is great
certified anya beef comes from cattle
that are usd a inspected antibiotic and
illness free born and raised within the
u.s no immigrant cows
and that meet the approved marbling
measurements just to name a few of their
criteria
better fed controls every aspect of
raising their cattle with diets designed
by phd ruminant nutritionists to
optimize for excellent beef quality
health
these guys
are incredible
i've bought from other companies and i
have to say
this is my favorite so far you can see
the marbling
is insane
and
i should know i eat a lot of beef these
guys are really good you should check
them out it gets delivered right to your
door flash frozen they're raised in the
midwest the cows are raised in the
midwest by 17 farming families their
motto's real beef from real families
if you want to know more about them you
can check them out on the beef producers
page of their website
they also practice whole animal butchery
so as much of the animal is used as
possible
their selections range from tomahawk and
sirloin steaks to their backyard
barbecue box
ribs liver heart
much more head over to the website at
betterfedbeef.com and use promo code mp
to get a whopping 20 off your first
order today that's code mp
at
betterfedbeef.com to try these guys this
is what i'm eating
they're good
hope you enjoy the rest of this episode
so what can
i say somebody watching this is
concerned about famine is there anything
that the average person can do to either
prepare or fight back yeah many things
one is
at this point now
in january of 2020 when i first started
warning about it we could have still
averted it at this point there's too
much inertia we're clearly going to have
global famines i don't actually and i'm
a very positive thinking type of a man
you know i just don't see a way out of
this at this point
so now it's down to mitigation right um
even though it hasn't really started in
earnest yet it's all about conditions
again amateurs always talk sparks it's
about conditions the conditions are set
for huge global famines one is it
depends on your conditions right
how you should prepare um
if you live
on key west so you've got one set of
issues and one set of you know it's warm
you don't have to worry about freezing
the depth
you're also not going to have a big farm
right you know i mean you're not going
to grow anything down there um
you're going to be short on food let's
say if you live in any of the island
nations if you live in japan which ex
imports about 70 of the food or so right
or if you live in hawaii imports about
90 of their food
you're going to be short
and you know you're going to be uh
bidding against the world on the price
of that food right uh like for instance
if i were in hawaii
i mean if i were if i were you know uh
some rich guy that lived on one little
island off from the south there you know
i would look at it differently than
living in honolulu i would be thinking
about going somewhere else but if you
live up in northern canada or i've been
up the yellow knife you know and that
sort of thing i'd be looking at it very
differently so first look at your own
circumstances where do you live uh what
are your economic conditions what are
your capabilities uh stocking up can can
be good for short-term sorts of things
that's what i've done as a work
correspondent uh basically hidden acorns
all over the place so if i get to one of
my acorns i'm good to go as a workhorse
model i can't just stop and grow a bunch
of food so that my set of problems so i
look at my problems what are my problems
as a workforce plan my my
my weaknesses are i'm traveling all the
time so i can't just stop and build a
compound you know and uh and not that
that would be necessarily the best way
to go anyway and my strengths are i do
travel around all the time and so and
and i'm very knowledgeable about
different circumstances around the world
and the united states and so i've
basically implement you know put little
acorns of food if i can get the one of
them i can
you know be there for a long period of
time and and be quite healthy and that
sort of thing but other people if you
live in new york city where are you
going to get your food from uh if your
electricity goes out if you're and and
the the thing is is famines tend to
cause a general a lot of people say
united states can't go into famine and
to that i would say you haven't studied
much yet you know the united states
absolutely can go into famine and at
this point parts of it certainly could
and at this point i would say probably
greater than 50 chance at this point
that parts of the united states will go
into famine between somewhere
i don't know 2023 2024 2025. it's all
about conditions right and right now
we're living off the food that we've
already produced right
and uh and our production is diminishing
uh
like it's going off the cliff right
so what would you do look at your own
circumstances
what are your own
capabilities how much resources do you
have
and
one of the most things most important is
as individuals we're all quite weak
right
one of my principal strengths
is i know a lot of highly capable people
so i've been working on my network right
and that's what everybody should work on
is their networks right your network of
people because as individuals we're all
quite weak but as teams we can be in
tribes you might say we can be strong or
even powerful right and so work on your
human network like for instance one uh
man and i use a veteran down in south
texas i met with him quite a bit he came
down to see me in mexico actually and we
talked about that
through he's like i'm going to take care
of my community he's taking charge of
this little town in texas so he's like
so i've been taking inventory
of who can do what he's like there's
this one old lady she's really worried
she's like
i don't have any money in all this he's
like well let's list down what are your
skills and she's like well
you know i can do this i know how to sew
and she knows how to canned food
one he's like canned food i need that
okay
you're gonna be our official food
counter because that's going to be
really important
and so you got a job you know make
yourself useful because once you once
you're like one of the things i'm very
useful for is accurate information
global recon and you know giving you
information that's actually actionable
right that makes me quite useful and so
i'll be welcoming any tribe because i i
can be eyes and ears right uh that lady
she can can food i need to eat you know
and so uh so we have to work as a team
and right we have to work um the doctor
can do doctor stuff you know
you know
that's how you have to everybody has
more skills than they even imagined
right you like there's more skills in
your head than you can even think about
right now you know what i mean because
you you're probably not normally
thinking about them because you're
normally focused on uh doing other
things like doing
your very important podcast and these
sorts of things but let's say you know
our communications do go down and you
can't do podcasts anymore for some
period of time well you need to focus on
other stuff and uh so you'll have to you
know dig into your repertoire and
like make yourself useful and one of
those things that you're obviously good
at is talking with people and uh because
i've watched quite a few of your
podcasts you you know i've talked with
people you're a good listener i continue
letting me ramble on and you know and
then
and that's like and uh and uh and um
and organizing
organize you know organizers are
incredibly important you know like that
man in south texas he's like
taking an inventory of his old town he
started with his church what are their
skills he's like i'm making a
spreadsheet who do i
he's getting people with radios because
he you know assuming phones may not work
or power goes down radio up right and uh
you know getting all them and you know
we'll get through this it's not like the
end of the world our everybody
listening to this
has
our families have been through all sorts
of hell our generations have been
through so many things
and uh
and we're here right so we're we're
natural survivors especially people that
are thinking ahead
not being afraid i'm a war court some
people say you know
since
january uh 2020 when i started warning
about famine uh people some people said
wow you've done so much war but you're
afraid now i'm not afraid i'm just
warning you uh i'm a war correspondent
i've been in more fire fights than
you've seen in most movies right it's
like i i don't like them and they're not
fun but at the same time i continue to
go back to them right so i mean i'm
gonna be fine i know i'm gonna be fine
and you're gonna be fine if you think
ahead and you work on your networks and
you think about your resilience make
sure you stockpile the things that you
need now that you won't be able to get
later uh like uh
canning supplies you know the types of
salts that you need the types of vinegar
the you know jars and a lot of stuff you
know what i mean and uh and then we'll
get through it and then when it's over
we'll be telling
uh children our children someday like
how bad it was and they'll think you're
exaggerating and you know
and uh yeah they'll be like it couldn't
have been that bad you'll be like yeah
well i was eating the horse's saddle i
had to boil it
oh my goodness
okay uh
if people want to follow you online or
want to go anywhere for more information
about this
do you have recommendations for them uh
i go on locals every day locals.com and
i have a website as well um
michael yawn.com my last name was y-o-n
yankee oscar november
and um
and i do a lot of interviews i have for
years
and uh but locals.com is where i've uh
published every day
and on locals i try to actually answer
uh questions actually on my own website
i don't normally answer questions but
i'll do it on locals because it's easier
for me
it doesn't i can quickly get it to them
um obviously i can't answer everything i
try but you know i work basically
and then sleep and then work
like you i'm sure
yeah yeah
okay well similar but not not quite not
exactly the same
thank you very much for coming on that
was really interesting i might have to
have you back on
just to talk about the entire picture
because i know this was a little bit
more focused
on famine but that was that was very
interesting so thank you for that
anytime you know how to reach me
nick ottens welcome to my podcast
thank you for having me
uh so before we get started can you give
a brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
uh so currently i'm a journalist based
in the netherlands
before i reported from spain i lived in
barcelona for a few years
and in the past i've worked for a number
of political risk consultancies and an
american non-profit and at the
non-profit i also worked on food and
agriculture issues
and now as a journalist i write mostly
about dutch
spanish and french politics and food and
agriculture is still one of my interests
okay great um let's let's get started
then
what is going on in the netherlands in
regards to the farmer's protest can you
just give a brief overview about what
that's about
so the protest started about four weeks
ago and the government put out a plan
for reducing emissions of nitrogen
the plan is to cut emissions in half by
2030 and since farms are the main
source of nitrogen emissions they
produce about 40 percent of overall
emissions they will have to reduce their
emissions by 40 percent
uh most of the farmers
were protesting are livestock farmers
because almost all of the nitrogen
that's belu that's produced in farming
is ammonia pollution which only comes
from livestock farms there are about 30
000 of them in the country
under the government's plans about
eleven thousand so one in three would
need to quit altogether
and another seventeen thousand which is
almost the remainder would need to
downsize
okay um
what's the protest trying to achieve
well also they're they're worried about
the cuts obviously and opposed to them
so many uh dairy farmers many pig
farmers
they're
they're struggling to break even most
years because the price of milk the
price of meat is more or less at
break-even price so they're saying if
you're going to ask us to
to remove 10 or 20 percent of our
animals that means we'll be bankrupt
so for them reductions within the
current model are not really an option
and obviously the farmers who would quit
are opposed to that because they want to
continue farming
how does the public in the netherlands
feel about the protest and what's going
on
so there's
there's a lot of sympathy with the
farmers if you look at the polls about
70 of people they understand why farmers
are upset
about 40 percent of people support the
protests themselves that have taken
place so they have blocked motorways and
food distribution centers with tractors
and another 35 are opposed to the
protest and the people in the middle
aren't sure so i think it's fair to say
that the country has kind of split down
the middle in terms of whether to
support the protests but when it comes
to supporting the farmers the clear
majority are sympathetic and they
understand why farmers are upset
um is it true that the netherlands is
the second largest food exporter in the
world
yes so after the united states we're the
second exporter of agricultural products
although it's worth knowing that
about nine percent of those experts are
flowers and bulbs so that's not food
and then another
27 or 29 are re-exports so those are
products for example imported from north
america or from south america which are
imported through the netherlands the
port of rotterdam and then go on to the
rest of europe
so for the remainder that's mostly food
products
but in order to export that much we also
have to import a lot
so we're the
the largest exporter of meat in europe
and the fifth largest exporter of dairy
in the world
most of those exports go to germany to
france to belgium and the uk so the
countries surrounding the netherlands
but we don't we're not a big country we
don't have a lot of land to grow cereals
and soy to feed the animals so that is
mostly imported from north america and
from south america
fed to the animals here and then the
products the dairy and the meat is
exported again to our neighboring
countries
do you think it's reasonable to expect
the netherlands to reduce their
emissions given the fact that they're
the second largest exporter
um
well it's not really much of a choice
because the government is sort of under
a legal obligation to
so these ammonia emissions have been in
excess of the legal limit
for 30 years
ever since these regulations were
introduced they are european regulations
for the protection for 30 years
the rules were introduced in the 1990s
and we have never met them
so it's not really a choice it's the
question is how how are we going to do
it so the reason it's such a concern is
because when there's too much ammonia
pollution
in the environment around farms
it actually helps certain plant species
grow but it means that other plants
whiffer and they die and those are
sources of
of nutrition
for insects
if those insect species disappear about
70 percent of the insect population of
the netherlands has disappeared in the
last 30 years
that means that a source of food for
birds disappears so we see
entire ecosystems collapse in the
country so it's not really a question of
whether to reduce emissions but how and
by how much
to go back to your question of course
that will affect exports it means that
if we want to feed our own people first
and we reduce farming it means that we
can export less or at least less dairy
and less meat products less milk less
eggs the other farming other types of
farming the growing of crops cucumbers
tomatoes paprika that's not affected and
those are major export products as well
and actually more profitable export
products the margin on dairy and meat is
pretty low
so
it's a question is it worth it to reduce
emissions
given that we're not making that money
and we're getting all of the all of the
pollution which is harmful to our
animals to our environment i think the
well at least the government decided it
is
um so with these new regulations do you
know how much
less meat and dairy will be exported
what percentage perhaps
no that's a bit hard to say so the
question now is
if we just make a 30 reduction in in
livestock farming which you would need
to do in order to achieve a 40 reduction
in emissions
you would say well there's one third
less dairy one third less meat right
but that's not necessarily the case you
there are various other options you
could either move further into the
direction of more intensive animal
farming so keeping a higher number of
animals on the same
on the same space at lower cost
but that tends to increase emissions
the alternative is switching in more in
the direction of organic farming
so having fewer animals on more land but
then of course the decrease in
production will be even steeper
because you simply have fewer animals
they will live longer they will live
healthier they'll be happier but you'll
have less meat you'll have less dairy
do you see any parallels or potential
parallels between what's happening in
the netherlands and what sri lanka tried
to implement with their organic farming
yeah well from what i know it seems that
they try to move very fast
and essentially ebola's factory farming
within a few years that's not a
reasonable goal to set on dutch farmers
for decades they have been pushed into
this sort of system by the banks and by
the companies that buy their products
and by the consumers who want cheap food
not just in the netherlands but also in
germany france belgium
to produce higher and higher volumes of
meat and dairy and eggs
at a lower and lower price
so the whole farm system has been
pushing them in that direction and
designed around that model of intensive
animal farming so you can't simply get
rid of that in a few years it needs to
be a transition
and the government needs to help which
it is it's making
32 billion euros available which is
about four percent of dutch gdp over the
next eight years
to help farmers either uh
to to to downsize
or to expropriate to buy out those
farmers who cannot continue or to
relocate them because there might also
be farmers who are now situated right
next to a conservation area where their
emissions are too high but if another
farmer quits somewhere else in the
country they might move they just need
some financial help to do so and
continue farming there
so there's a lot of money there is time
there's eight years to meet this call to
get there
it still won't be easy
but i don't expect a sri lanka like
scenario because i don't i think that
the dutch government is a little wiser
than that i hope
um
do you think are are people concerned
about the unintended consequences for
people who depend on these food exports
well sure um
first of all they're the consumers in
other countries who depend on them
although i wouldn't expect people in
germany and in belgium to starve if we
produce less meat
but we also export all over the world so
it's a fair concern
and there is a whole industry that is
dependent on the farmers so you have the
companies that produce the animal feed
which they sell to the farmers they're
the logistical companies which transport
products there's the meat and dairy
processing industry there's the
supermarkets all of those that employs
tens of uh tens of thousands of people
in the country so there's a lot of
people whose livelihoods depend on this
and there will be people who
will lose their jobs will lose their
business as a result
um
do you think this has anything to do
with kind of the push for more
plant-based that's been going around i
think around the world or is this purely
climate
it's yeah it's kind of the other way
around this it's not so much that the
the move towards a more plant-based diet
is the reason for doing this it's more
that we need to do this because of the
the ammonia emissions which are
local uh destructive to our nature
and in order to be able to do that
we should switch to a more plant-based
diet because we'll just won't be able to
produce the volumes of dairy and meat
that we have for the last 20-30 years
okay
let me see what else i have here
okay so you talked a little bit about
the local benefit of reducing nitrogen
emissions
what happens if the emissions aren't
reduced
so then you see a continuation of what
we've been seeing now to be fair
the farmers have reduced
nitrogen emissions by a lot
in the last 30 years by about 65 percent
so that has been a large
improvement
to the conservation areas to the local
nature
to the quality of our air to the quality
of groundwater but it hasn't been enough
to arrest this decline
uh in the loss of biodiversity so you
see that insect populations are
shrinking you see that certain bird
species which are very common in the
netherlands 20 30 40 years ago
have become rare
so we need to reduce further in order to
give
to give these conservation areas a
chance to recover and if we don't well
then we'll just have to accept that we
failed and that we need to give up these
conservation areas
if farms begin to close in fairly large
numbers
will the remaining farmers be able to
make up the difference in food
production or will the total output
be less
well that's an interesting question so
if you look at as in i'm not sure
but i hope they will be if you look at
just the reductions
and you would assume that everybody else
continues to farm as they do now then
the answer would be no
however there are many innovations which
could help so there are innovations in
growing crops in horticulture in
growing in greenhouses
where you'll be able to increase
production
there is innovation in cultivated meat
or what people might call lab grown meat
there are two dutch companies which are
quite large and one of them just this
week announced that they have been able
to
lab grow the first pork sausage
in order to do that they will still need
animal tissue
so they need to work with farmers to get
animal cells which they then take to
their left to their facilities to grow
meat
that could be a new model for
farmers and for the dutch food industry
to at the very least maintain the level
of meat production that we have now and
potentially grow it because there's huge
growth potential in these companies they
only need a little bit of animal
material in order to i don't know grow
40 stakes
so
we might actually if we invest in that
then at the end
of the of the day in 2030 our beet
production might actually be higher with
fewer farmers and fewer farm animals
do you know much about uh the lab-grown
meat like when they grow meat do they
grow a muscle tissue do you know how
that work like is that what the end
product is
yeah i'm not i haven't actually seen it
it in the flesh
but the way that that's been described
to me is they take animal cells and
understood in a certain growth medium it
is grown and at the end of the process
you have a piece of meat which looks and
tastes and smells exactly like a real
piece of meat food and in a sense you
might argue it is real meat because it
starts with an animal
animal tissue animal cells
so the dutch government is subsidizing
for 60 million euros research and
education into this field
there are two large dutch companies
which are active globally so i i have
high hopes that this could be a not a
complete replacement but a an important
addition
to the animal farming that we do and
also help those animal farmers who
remain
to actually make more money
than they do now because right now most
animal farmers they don't make a lot of
profit the price of meat supermarkets
always want the lowest price
consumers aren't willing to pay that's
much more and now the government is
saying get rid of 20 of your cows or 20
of your pigs
this could be a huge help to them if
they are able to sell animal tissue to
cultivated meat companies at a good
price
to combine those two types of farming to
on the one hand provide animal cells to
cultivated meat companies and on the
other hand sell the meat of their own
animals as a sort of a luxury product
after they've had a full and normal life
so these laws um you said they're being
implemented by the government but they
have been around a while and it's it's
more being implemented from the european
union
there well the thing is the european
union hasn't implemented them at all so
they have been telling us for 30 years
every year they've been writing a letter
to the dutch government saying you're
not meeting the rules you're not meeting
the rules but they haven't taken any
action
it's only
that
since the dutch
supreme court ruled three years ago that
a dutch government was not doing enough
that it forced the dutch government
into action to come up with a plan
and that plan is here now
it's a european rule but europe doesn't
have the capability to enforce it and
they haven't enforced it it's a dutch
government that is now finally choosing
to enforce it
okay and i think i asked this before but
do you think it's reasonable to put such
a large exporter of meat under the same
emission laws as other like countries in
europe
well there that's what some of the
farmers and some of the meat industry
are arguing
saying we have to follow the same strict
regulations but we produce so much more
and we have so much less space
is it really fair
well we should have argued that 30 years
ago when we were making the rules like
we made this agreement and we haven't
kept our word to our other european
partners for 30 years so now if we go
back to brussels and argue for leniency
then the european commission will say no
like we haven't we haven't forced you to
take action but we're also not going to
make the rules uh
looser now
i think
another point which is sort of related
to this is the question is it fair to
put it all on the farmers
and there i think the answer is no
because it's not just the farmers
there's a whole industry around it so if
you look at just agriculture per se
that's about 1.4 percent of the dutch
economy but if you add up all of the
companies that are working around
farmers so the meat processing industry
the dairy processing industry
supermarket slaughterhouses animal feed
company the companies that build the
technology that's 6.4 of the economy so
that's a large sector
and the banks who give the loans to the
farmers
the big companies are making the most
money they have the financial buffers
to invest
in a transition to a form of agriculture
that is less polluting and more animal
friendly it's unreasonable to expect the
farmers to do this all by themselves
that's for sure
okay let's see what else do i have to
ask about this do you think anything's
going to come of the protests how long
have they been going on
so for four weeks
you see that they're becoming a bit less
intense than when they started in the
beginning there were demonstrations
outside parliament outside the home of
the the minister of nature policy there
were death threats there were
fires there were riots
now it's mostly been peaceful protests
but they do continue
the government has appointed a mediator
in an attempt to
to meet with representatives of farmers
to try to work out
a solution
the government has set national goals
but the provincial governments or sort
of the state government
they will have to implement
the policy at a local level and
translate those goals into
local policies so deciding on a
case-by-case basis which farms need to
go which function to stay which farms
need to downsize so there is a lot of
room for flexibility over the next few
years to try to
save as many farms as possible
but the government has been very clear
that we are not going to reduce the goal
of
cutting emissions in half by 2030.
that's sort of set
and then how to achieve it there is room
for for flexibility
um
and you talked about it a little bit but
can you describe again
how it would be possible to achieve this
like what flexibility is there other
than shutting down some of these farms
yeah so there are actually quite a lot
of options um
so the possibility of relocating imagine
you're a farmer you're situated right
next to a conservation
area if you move two kilometers away
that could already make a big impact on
the emissions in that conservation area
because the emissions are pretty local
there is technology so there are
machines which can capture the ammonia
emissions from the stables
and recycle it either into fertilizer or
into a biogas
that's expensive though but the
technology exists so that could be a
solution for quite a number of farms
there is cheaper technology to separate
dung and urine
so that less ammonia is produced from
the manure of animals in the first place
that also requires investments in the
stables but there are many farmers who
have already made those investments in
the last like 10 years and they have
seen reductions
all of those things could add up
farms that are currently 100
livestock farmers they could also say if
they wanted to reduce by say 50
and grow crops in addition to livestock
farming crops which might serve as
animal feed
they would probably need financial help
to make it work
but that could also that would
significantly
reduce emissions and it would also
improve the welfare of the animals and
the health of the animals because
currently we give them a lot of sort of
synthetic food because natural food is
more expensive
biological or organic farming is still
pretty small as a share of overall
farming it's like five percent but it is
growing and that too is something that
can help
because you have lower emissions
from organic farming and the eu goal is
to achieve 25 organic farming in 2030
i kind of doubt we'll make that since
we're coming from five percent to grow
to 25 percent but growing towards that
goal and there are many farmers who want
to
uh would help but again that needs that
their products will be more expensive so
they will need financial help to make
that work okay so you said that five to
twenty five percent for organic farming
which isn't like basically zero to one
hundred which is what happened in sri
lanka
well that i think that's a bit of an
exaggeration
but it is a lot it's a it needs to
increase by a lot in order to beat the
eu target
the interesting thing is a majority of
farmers want to switch to organic
farming
because
it's
they will require less fertilizer less
animal feed
they will use
less pesticides less antibiotics
for animals because they're healthier
and i think for a farmer it's just more
enjoyable to have
fewer animals so that you can actually
take more individual care of them
but it is expensive and right now
it doesn't look like a majority of
consumers are willing to pay that
premium
so i think what needs to happen is in
that
chain in between farmer and consumer all
of those companies
which are taking out a little bit of the
profit
until the product reaches the consumer
they all need to chip in
so the meat processing the dairy
processing companies the
supermarkets the logistics companies the
wholesalers
they all need to accept a lower profit
margin on organic products so that by
the time it reaches the store the price
difference between organic farming and
the products that come out of the
factory farming is reduced
i think that's the way to make it work
is the government so you said the
government is offering money to farmers
how is that getting into farmers hands
uh so that's
like sort of a two-step level because
the central government is giving money
to the provincial governments and then
they will decide which farms can stay
and which need to go and the ones that
need to go will receive compensation
based on the value of their land
so it's just the value of their land at
the time and that's the amount of money
they get
that also still needs to be worked out
because farmers are arguing well
that's fine but i have two billion euros
in debt with a bank
so you can pay me for my for my land but
i need to pay off that loan
and then the government is saying well
we don't want all of that money to
eventually end up with the bank which
has been making all these loans so
that's another thing that needs to be
worked out in more detail over the next
few months to make sure that farmers
actually get to keep
that compensation
it probably won't be a hundred percent
for uh all farmers especially if they
have uh
high debts and little land
but it needs to be worked out in a way
that is fair obviously
so so part of the protests i suppose are
people who are concerned about
bankruptcy yes
absolutely and they're they're afraid of
being left with
a huge debt with the bank
the same bank that has been encouraging
them to invest
in larger stables in technology so their
debts have been growing in order to meet
previous regulations for emissions for
animal welfare so you can imagine that
the average farmer
sort of feels
sort of exhausted by this because
they've been trying and they have been
doing their best to meet so many rules
and regulations over the last 20 30
years now there's something else
and it could result in them losing their
fun
so it i understand the
the frustration
but
something also needs to be done because
we're just not meeting our obligations
and we are not we are not taking good
care of our natural environment
um how do you feel
about kind of the i don't know whether
or not it's propaganda or misinformation
but
other information that's been going out
online regarding the farmer's protests i
know there's been a quite a bit in the
u.s um kind of equating the farmers with
well the canadian truckers for example
or people fighting for
for freedom
um how much of that is true
well i think that there is a commonality
where you see
um
sort of this divide in many western
countries between the big city and the
countryside
and people in more rural areas feel that
the people in charge people in the
government
they don't understand our way of life
they are making these decisions over our
heads
so i think that's a commonality
although the netherlands is such a small
country that the difference between city
and countryside i mean if i take a train
from amsterdam in an hour i reached my
parents home they live
in the middle of the countryside if i
take a
train the other way in an hour i'm in
belgium so the difference between city
and countryside is much smaller here
than in the u.s in canada or even spain
or france
but it does exist like there is a
different
a difference a different way of life
and i it doesn't help
when uh politicians who have been
raised in the city who live in the big
city who
don't really know the countryside well
need to make these decisions and the
farmers there
the organizations which are meant to
represent them
um they are left in negotiations
so
you get a a clash where the two sides
aren't talking with each other anymore
and maybe that has something in common
too like this sense of alienation of not
understanding each other like talking at
a different level
i think that there there is a
commonality with with what's going on in
other in other democracies
uh you've i think you've mentioned this
already too but what percentage of the
uh meat industry or the dairy industry
actually is exported versus just feeding
people in the netherlands
i i
i don't remember exactly i thought it
was about 40
okay so quite a big
chunk of that goes to other countries
yes for sure and like don't pin me down
on the number yeah yeah
but a lot for sure
and
if
as i mentioned these these reductions go
through you would see a significant
decrease
in dutch exports of dairy indeed
okay and people aren't worried about
this causing food shortages or is that
part of the concern
i know because most of these products
they're exported to germany to france to
the uk into belgium so these are not
countries that are going to starve just
because we're able to sell them less
yogurt and less less sausages
now the concern i think is more
uh with the livelihood of farmers and
that some farms
will just relocate to these countries go
to germany go to belgium set up farms
there
and then you're also
relocating the emissions
so then germany will have the same
problem in a few years if they need to
produce more of their own meat some of
them will be dutch farmers coming to
germany and then their emissions of
ammonia will go up and then we have
solved our problem but we have created a
whole new problem for the germans for
example
are there other countries in europe that
produce far under the
the amount of i guess ammonia you're
allowed to produce
well yes because the it's not so much a
total amount
although if you look at the total the
netherlands has the highest emissions of
ammonia per hectare in the eu
but it's
more the
uh how much buffer do you have around it
so that the the
the conservation areas nature trees the
water the grounds can absorb the amount
of ammonia so we pollute so much ammonia
in such a small country
that is just too much for the plants for
our for the quality of our soil to
handle it
this is why they don't have this problem
in france or in germany or in spain
because they have a farm industry that
is sort of the same size as ours
but much more land
so the emissions spread out
okay
that all makes sense let me see do i
have any other questions here
i think that
i think that
pretty much covered it is there anything
else you want to mention about what's
going on
um
well you might those are the political
implications obviously for the
government
so the we have a a coalition government
of center left and center right parties
so they're pretty much in the middle
and they're so they're in a
impossible situation because on the one
hand they need the support of left-wing
parties because they don't have a
majority
who want to go further or want to go
fast
on the other hand the the ruling
christian democrats and the ruling
liberal party and liberal is a
center-right party here
they have a lot of supporters in the
countryside
so
they feel resistance from their own
voters from their own provincial
deputies
saying this is too much for us this is
going to cost us votes in the next
election
but if they make concessions then the
left-wing parties whom they also need
will
withdraw their support or force the
government to resign
so it's sort of an impossible situation
for the parties in the middle
whatever they do they will be unpopular
yeah that's for sure um um what do you
think about the
kind i don't know exactly what to call
it but the idea going around that this
is just the government stealing land
under the guise of ammonia reduction
no that's that's like going one step
too far
the government does need land to build
houses because we also have a huge
housing shortage in the country about
three hundred thousand
uh but you don't need that much land to
build houses like half of the
netherlands is agricultural land if you
just take one percentage of that you
would have enough land to build 300 000
homes
the problems is with the permitting so
the court case that happened three years
ago where the dutch supreme court said
that the government is not doing enough
to reduce ammonia emissions
or nitrogen emissions of which ammonia
apart
that put on
on hold all of the construction permits
because when you build a road or a house
or whatever you also release a little
bit of nitrogen and the judges said you
are already releasing too much nitrogen
you can't emit more
so in the last three years we have
barely been able to build homes so we
need to solve this problem
in order to
start this permitting process again so
we can build roads so we can build
houses so we so companies can expand so
in that sense there is a link between
the farm crisis and the housing crisis
interesting
okay
interesting okay well i think that
answers all the questions i had um if
people wanted to read more about this is
there anywhere they can go online well
they should go to my website they could
go to atlantic sentinel.com that's my
blog
and there has been some coverage in the
international press about this as well
but
not that much surprisingly because i
think it actually has implications
globally like to me
we have sort of reached the limits of
factory farming in the netherlands
so they think that's a warning to other
countries which are on that same
trajectory that if you don't do anything
you'll be in the same situation we are
in 10 or 20 years from now
so i hope there will be more interest
and i'm sure
your show will help to generate more
interest in the topic hopefully yes
okay well thank you very much for coming
on i'll link your blog in the
description if anybody's interested in
checking it out but thank you again
thank you so much